how did slack wind up being worth 28
billion dollars isn't it just a basic
irc clone not quite every weekday
millions of people spend over 1 billion
minutes using slack but slack is more
than just a cool way for office workers
to discuss projects it's also the
culmination of stuart butterfield's
lifelong obsession with creating ways
for us to connect with each other this
is the amazing story of slack and the
people who created it even by the
standards of tech ceos stuart
butterfield's journey is an unorthodox
one it began in a log cabin in a small
fishing town called lund british
columbia since being settled in the late
19th century by two brothers from sweden
lund had become a magnet for people who
wanted to throw off the shackles of the
conventional lifestyle pioneers schemers
dreamers hippies basically people like
stewart's parents david and norma
butterfield influenced by the huge
cultural upheavals of the late 1960s
they met in montreal in the early 1970s
fell in love and went as far west as
they could to the very end of the
sunshine coast highway they settled in
lund and decided to join a commune there
back to the log cabin that's where
stewart was born
only that wasn't his name because
stewart came into this world as dharma
jeremy butterfield the family spent five
years in lond before david and norma
decided to move to victoria the capital
of british columbia david who built the
log cabin that was their home for years
by himself entered the real estate
industry and ended up becoming one of
the city's most prominent sustainable
developers dharma meanwhile received his
first computer at seven years of age he
loved it of course something he loved
less was his birth name though at age 12
dharma changed his name to stuart
because it was the most normal name he
could think of already a creative and
precocious boy stewart as he was now
known thrived at school his first love
was philosophy and he was good enough at
it to earn a masters in philosophy from
the university of cambridge but
philosophy wasn't the only love stewart
discovered at school because that's
where via accessing his school's
mainframe he first used the internet
stuart loved finding and building
communities a big fan of the band fish
he spent a lot of time on their news
group talking to people around the world
looking back it's easy to see how this
taught him about the power of connection
and the power of technology to create it
his fascination with computers went
beyond the social around this time
stuart started building websites a seed
had been planted flash forward to 1998
stuart had finished his masters and was
considering a phd but his friends back
home kept talking about the burgeoning
tech scene stewart realized that it was
a lot bigger than when he'd left and
everyone seemed to be having a great
time so stewart dropped the phd plan and
moved to vancouver to join a startup
called communicate.com spoiler alert
things didn't work out but before the
company went broke stuart found his
escape hatch he decided to collaborate
with one of his communicate.com
co-workers jason classen jason had a
side hustle called grad finder it was
basically a way for people to find their
old acquaintances from school or college
and then keep in touch with them sounds
familiar doesn't it and it was also an
experience which deepened stewart's
fascination with developing better ways
for people to connect stewart and jason
worked on grad finder together for about
a year before selling it to another.com
company satisfied with his first exit
and some money in his bank account
stewart decided to take a year off
financial scandals and the failure of
overvalued companies to deliver on big
promises made to exuberant investors
brought web 1.0 to a shuttering halt
uber and undeterred stewart started a
devblog which quickly gained a following
and it's around this time that he met
katarina fate who he began dating and
then eventually got married to all of a
sudden stewart had eric he had jason his
co-worker from communicate.com and he
had his partner katarina this group
decided to build something together they
were staring at some huge challenges
funding had dried up after the bursting
of the dot-com bubble browser technology
was still rudimentary but they were
inspired by the same thing that brought
them together in the first place that
intense desire to help people connect so
they channeled that inspiration into
their first collaborative venture they
decided to create a massively
multiplayer online game today mmos are
everywhere but this was 2002 world of
warcraft wasn't released until 2004 so
they were out there on the leading edge
stewart and his co-workers called their
company ludicorp ludic means to show
spontaneous and undirected playfulness
so they knew what kind of experience
they wanted to create the game was
called game never ending people liked it
but the founders couldn't raise enough
money to build what they really wanted
to but this tale was about to undergo a
big twist the kind you couldn't script
stuart and katarina were in new york for
a conference stuart must have eaten the
wrong thing because he contracted food
poisoning the way he tells the story he
was in their hotel room unable to sleep
and on the verge of hallucination that
brief illness triggered a profound
revelation what if he reasoned ludicorp
could apply the technology they'd
already created to build a new kind of
customer experience inspired and
possibly still delirious stewart wrote
down as many ideas as he could summon on
scraps of paper one of his realizations
was that players of game never ending
could add other photos to their profile
beyond their stock display picture
stewart figured that this could be
adapted into a photo sharing service the
increasing popularity of early digital
cameras gave him confidence that he was
on to a good idea but despite how good
the idea was the technology didn't quite
exist yet and four people simply weren't
enough to solve the engineering problem
so stuart did what every great
technology leader does he found a
solution and he did it by applying his
unique gift a deep understanding of how
people and ideas connect stuart knew a
guy cal henderson today cal is the cto
of slack but back then cal was a huge
fan of game never ending but he was
smarter than your average fan in fact he
had figured out how to hack his way into
ludicorp's email servers and read all of
the internal mailing lists this was an
incredibly bold move but he just wanted
to help out cal actually emailed the
team and said i know about your game i
would love to come and work on it and i
think i can help you fix the issues that
you're talking about stewart could have
reacted badly to cal's mischief and then
who knows how this entire story would
have panned out instead he realized that
he had an elite developer on his hands
one who wasn't afraid to break the rules
so stewart and his team got in touch
with cal who remember had already read
their emails and asked if he'd be
interested in helping them build their
new service cal jumped at the
opportunity and came on board despite
being based in the uk it was december
2003 when stewart and the team committed
to building flickr it was a big bet on
that same concept that people are
constantly seeking new and better ways
to connect the team launched flickr at
the e-tech conference in san diego the
following february once you factor in
the holidays that's about a month and a
half of dev time it was more than bold
it was kind of insane but they did it
flickr was novel because it allowed
people to share and show off their
photos beyond their immediate social
circle it was also novel technologically
people hadn't really seen anything that
could display photos so crisply and
conveniently native in a browser before
bloggers absolutely loved flickr it
meant that they could actually host
photos on their sites their strong
support generated big word-of-mouth buzz
for flickr and helped contribute to
impressive organic growth thanks in part
to that strong support flickr was soon
doubling in size every month and
important people were paying attention
reid hoffman who had just founded
linkedin and esther dyson who was a
well-known angel investor put money in
the company and three of the biggest
internet companies of the era google
yahoo and ask jeeves of course were all
showing interest in buying the company
flickr was also attracting vc interest
but the vc landscape was very different
in 2004 than it is today it was much
smaller and much less mature yahoo
emerged as the most serious contender
and by the end of 2004 it purchased
flickr for about 25 million dollars
today it's hard to imagine a successful
internet company that builds an
impressive product captures a loyal
audience and grows so quickly selling
for that kind of money founders are
encouraged to create a unicorn before
being bought out or going public after
all instagram in so many ways the
spiritual successor to flickr was bought
by facebook for a billion dollars in
2012 only eight years later they had
just 13 employees at the time but this
was 2004. by the standards of those days
it was still a decent amount but yahoo
didn't just want flickr they also wanted
stewart and his team the deal included a
three-year earn out a feature of mergers
whereby part of the purchase price is
contingent on the seller meeting certain
performance targets after the
acquisition this meant that not only did
game never ending need to stay on the
back burner but stewart and the rest of
his team would need to move to san
francisco so they could keep building
flicker from inside of yahoo it made
some sense on paper at the time yahoo
was a big company with resources and
credibility beyond the injection of
capital they could have provided flickr
with the kind of engineering expertise
they needed to take it to the next level
in reality it was kind of a disaster
yahoo's size also created bureaucracy
office politics and a frustrating
corporate culture they stayed for the
three year earn out period but katarina
eric and jason left as soon as they
could steward actually stayed on a
little longer although by the middle of
2008 he was gone too his surreal
resignation email which mentioned his
desire to tend to his small but growing
alpaca herd and get back to tin his
first love was an instant classic
reflecting on his time with yahoo he
called the company a terrible joke and
said that innovation at flickr turned
blue and choked out after the
acquisition but moments of adversity
often contain the seeds of future
success steward hated his time at yahoo
but he learned a lot about how he didn't
want to build his next company and he
would apply those lessons in spectacular
style burnt out stewart went back to
vancouver to gather his thoughts
unfortunately he did so by himself
around this time he and katarina split
up katarina became a really successful
entrepreneur in her own right so their
story did kind of have a happy ending
cal eric and jason got in touch with
stewart and told him that they wanted to
work on something together again it's
now early 2009 the recession which would
spill over into the global financial
crisis was beginning to bite that wasn't
the only way the world had changed
though online multiplayer gaming had
grown up world of warcraft was a huge
hit so the team of four stepped back
into that world but they didn't go back
to ludicorp or game never ending they
decided to start something new and they
were determined to do things differently
they called their new company tiny spec
and the game glitch stewart and his team
specifically designed glitch to be
non-violent they were fascinated by its
potential for mutual creation and
collaboration it was idealistic in an
age before peaceful co-op games like
stardew valley and animal crossing it
actually seemed kind of quaint and again
there it is like a lighthouse in the fog
that obsession with creating better ways
for us to connect thanks to stewart's
profile and track record they were able
to quickly raise 17.5 million from high
profile investors like a16z and excel
with money in the bank tiny spec was
able to scale up they hired about 40
engineers and designers spread across
north america they encountered a problem
how could they collaborate effectively
as a team when they were scattered to
the winds it turned out this problem was
tailor-made for stewart's obsession at
first the glitch team used irc internet
relay chats you know i put on my robe
and wizard hat that kind of stuff chat
rooms basically irc did a serviceable
job of helping the tiny spec team
onboard new starters but they were
engineers they were constantly looking
for ways to optimize the team realized
that they could build in new features
around irc to make it more user friendly
they built a bunch of new tools and
called the system line feed they noticed
that it really enhanced their
productivity so much so that they were
able to launch glitch in september of
2011. it seemed to have all the key
ingredients of a massive success a great
team which had been backed by renowned
investors launching an exciting new
product to lots of fanfare and it was a
beautiful utopian idea for a game
unfortunately it was also a big flop
whether it was because people didn't
understand it or just plain didn't like
it by november glitch was back in beta a
stewart put it they basically unlaunched
and tried to tinker with it in order to
actually find an audience it took a year
of trying until october 2012 for stuart
to come to the most difficult
realization that any founder can have
things were not going to work out
although there was still about five
million dollars in the bank revenue
wasn't growing quickly enough to really
scale the business
stewart wrote an email to his board
explaining his decision then he called
an all hands meeting and broke the bad
news to his staff everyone except for
the four co-founders and four other
staff were let go stewart even had to
tell an employee who had just relocated
his family across the country that he no
longer had a job it was gut wrenching
but he was determined to do things the
right way the remnants of the team
created a website called hire a genius
and created profiles for all the former
glitch employees to help them find their
next jobs they even uploaded all the
code and all the art files from glitch
to the public domain as a demonstration
of what they built together and that
email i mentioned earlier the one stuart
wrote to his board john o'farrell was
the board member from andres and
horowitz he forwarded stewart's email to
marc andreessen mark's concise reply
showed not only their faith in stewart
but also how they grew into such a
legendary vc firm he wrote that it is
what it is if history repeats itself and
they come up with the next flicker all
will still end well mark stewart and his
team still had about four million
dollars in cash they had a great
development team they had faithful
investors and they had an idea this idea
would become the ultimate expression of
the passion that animated stuart
butterfield's life and career building
new ways for people to connect but marc
andreessen was wrong they didn't come up
with another flicker they built
something much bigger encouraged by
their experience in building line feed
the internal chat used by the glitch
team and flickr
stewart and his team decided that they
wanted to build a new internal chat
platform but they weren't the only ones
with that idea hipchat which launched in
2010 was also attempting to build an
internal work chat it took off and
before long local developers were
boasting about working at places which
used hipchat atlassian pounced an
acquired hipchat in march of 2012. the
emergence of multiple enterprise
communication platforms all around the
same time drives home something which is
really important for founders to
understand you can have a great idea you
can be a brilliant manager you can
optimize for everything under your
control but you still need things to
align for basically the last 20 years
it's been possible to boil down what
enables modern tech businesses to
succeed to just three things one the
emergence of fast stable internet and
mobile technology two the creation of
new social use cases and three a
business model that enables frictionless
scaling this is the golden triad that so
many modern tech companies wind up
satisfying and then growing massively
tiny spec realized that the moment for
line feed had arrived so they pivoted
and committed 100
to building something that could take on
and beat the competition it's easy to
assume that investors would be jumping
all over them after all steward had a
track record of building a cool company
that people loved and flickr people also
knew him and liked him but no matter how
you sliced it tiny speck had failed
investors weren't sure if stewart was up
for the grind of building a company that
could grow beyond enthusiastic early
adopters and the market was already
becoming more crowded but excel and
andreas and horowitz kept the faith and
maintained their support everyone agreed
that one of the first things the new
company needed was a catchier name
linefeed wouldn't cut it so naturally
stewart and the team came up with
searchable log of all conversation and
knowledge slack for short thankfully the
full name was basically never used in
any pitch decks or marketing materials
but it's a clue to how the team was
thinking the next step was to build an
attractive user interface if you
remember irc it was really bare bones in
terms of appearance and usability the
team worked hard to build the ideal user
interface and it worked it was beautiful
innovative and full of integrations
stewart and the team had a great early
stage product but they had a problem
they struggled to convince their friends
at other companies to use it time and
time again they'd approached them only
to be told we already used hipchat why
would we change when you're trying to
persuade people that they should
implement what is basically an entirely
new way of communicating at work you
need to nail the messaging you need to
convince them that this use case is
meaningfully different from email that
sending dozens or even hundreds of
messages back and forth every day will
actually enhance productivity and not
destroy it and that it can improve team
culture the contagion effect that we see
so often in consumer and enterprise
software only works if new users become
evangelists for the product they have to
love it enough to tell others to use it
that's what happened with slack social
media helped to build the buzz the team
launched slack in a preview release in
august of 2013. 8 000 companies signed
up for the wait list and only two weeks
later 15 000 companies had signed up
they actually had to stagger the launch
so they could add enough server capacity
for all the demand to be met by february
2014 10 000 new users were joining slack
every single day they already had 150
000 paying users do you remember how
earlier i talked about the golden triad
of modern tech companies technological
feasibility social use case and scaling
business model well it was now time for
stuart and his team to develop the
business model that would secure their
success to do so they drew on their
experience in the gaming world lots of
people would have probably set the bar
for the paid version of a product like
slack at the number of users within an
organization slack did something
different they could see that linearly
scaling the cost by the number of users
would make slack a really tough sell for
big organizations so rather than the
number of users they set the pay gate at
the number of messages in the archive
that you could access think about it if
you're working for a dynamic move fast
and break stuff type company you're
probably sending hundreds of messages a
day and you're probably not spending
much time on proper documentation so
imagine if you make a big breakthrough
on a tough project and then you're not
able to go back and retrace your steps
or imagine how hard it would be to join
a company like that if you weren't able
to get up to speed by reading important
archived messages there were other
things too like a cap on the number of
integrations you can add to the free
version compared to the paid version
plus slack's ui was always more
appealing to non-developers tons of
government departments political offices
and not-for-profits use slack but the
core of the business model was that once
a company got hooked on slack they would
become dependent on it for their project
management and their onboarding of new
employees with a beautiful product and
an elegant business model in place
stewart was ready to build a great team
he even rehired developers from his old
tiny spec crew yet again we see his
innate understanding of the value of
staying connected slack started going to
the moon its revenues grew from 12
million dollars in 2014 to 30 million
dollars the following year 100 million
in 2016 200 million in 2017 in the
summer of 2018 with revenues of 221
million and 8 million daily active users
slack cemented its dominance over
hipchat by buying it this really sealed
it slack had become unassailable in the
enterprise chat market later that year
rumors were starting to circulate that
slack was about to go public by this
stage stewart had fielded tons of
acquisition offers after the bad
experience of yahoo acquiring flickr he
knew he wanted to wait for the right
opportunity but there was a big elephant
in the room slack may have conquered
hipchat but microsoft which was still
the biggest game in town when it came to
enterprise software had launched teams
in march of 2017. it was able to
leverage microsoft's huge user base to
very quickly become the largest
enterprise communications platform
around stewart wasn't exactly pleased by
microsoft's entry into the market slack
brought an anti-trust complaint against
microsoft in the european union in
mid-2020 alleging that microsoft has
illegally tied its team's product into
its market dominant office productivity
suite and made it too hard to uninstall
it i won't discuss the details of that
ongoing case in this video but it's safe
to say that there's some bad blood
between microsoft and slack slack's
other challenge was very familiar to
anyone with a knowledge of modern tech
companies it had never actually
generated a profit it had a great
product and a solid business model but
it was totally focused on growth not
squeezing more money out of existing
users but they had a lot of cash and
capacity to generate more of it and
their product and branding meant that
they didn't need to market themselves to
prospective investors which meant that
there was less of a need for bankers and
their big fees to get involved stuart
didn't really need to raise more money
for the company this meant that a direct
public offering a dpo rather than an ipo
could be the best option it's an
approach which often makes sense for a
consumer-facing company like slack or
spotify which went public via a dpo in
2018. slack announced their intention to
file a dpo in april of 2019. on thursday
june 20th shares of slack began trading
they closed at 38.62
up almost 50 percent in a single day and
equivalent to a 19.5 billion dollar
market cap of course that's not the end
of the story the pressure of competing
with big tech companies led the share
price to fall as low as 16
things weren't looking good but after
months of speculation salesforce the
leader in crm completed its acquisition
of slack for 27.7 billion dollars in
mid-2021 stuart butterfield had taken
the natural human desire to connect and
used it to build a massive tech company
worth tens of billions of dollars but
the story doesn't end there discord
offers many of the same features as
slack and is now growing even faster so
in order to understand how discord is
changing communication you have to watch
this video about how the founder managed
to become a billionaire without going to
an ivy league school or ever working at
a big tech company it's a really
fascinating story thanks for watching